hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm finally able to tell you about
something that we have been working on
for over a year
this is cloak now cloak is our clothing
brand this is something that we've been
working on for a long time because we
wanted to make clothing that we were
proud to tell you about we decided that
we wanted to make something and by the
way when I say we I mean jacksepticeye
and I and a team of very smart very
knowledgeable people about clothing and
how to make a company responsibly have
put together our heads to try to make
clothing that we would want to wear
clothes that wasn't just screaming its
name at the top of his lungs clothes
that we would be proud to wear clothes
that we would be proud of where it came
from of who it represented and who was
four and more specifically it's for you
this is something that we wanted to make
to be accessible to everybody something
that wasn't restricting someone based on
what type of person they were what kind
of thing they did is something that
people could really identify with they
could identify was something that didn't
want to really be identified because the
clothing is subtle what we wanted was
something that didn't have huge branding
about what it was clothes that was
inherently high-quality clothes that fit
well clothes that was comfortable
clothes that just was something that you
could wear every single day and be happy
wearing it we wanted all these things
and it's shocking how hard that is to
get in clothing today every company is
so worried about shouting their brand at
the top of their lungs that they kind of
forgot about the people that are wearing
the clothes in the first place we wanted
this for you and it's not just
sweatshirts either it's a whole we
wanted to make a different assortment of
clothes that you could wear in pretty
much any circumstance we got sweatshirts
we've got t-shirts obviously we've got
this which is a long sleeve zip up kind
of athletic wear kind of thing and as
you can see on all these things it's not
overtly branded everything about this
company is about hiding in plain sight
we wanted to have these subtle logos and
I love this logo by the way because it's
just so simple and nice we wanted to
have things
people could really enjoy things that
were comfortable things that fit well
things that weren't going to fall apart
on you on the second where we wanted
clothing for you you can go to cloak
brand calm right now to check out what
we have but it is for pre-sale if you
order now you should get it before the
end of the year but we wanted to be very
slow and careful with the launch so it
might sell out very quickly we're not a
hundred percent sure we wanted to make
sure that everything was smooth and
consistent for everybody so go to cloak
brand comm check out the stuff we have
and submit your pre-order right now you
can also go to cloak brand on Instagram
or any of the social media handles and
tomorrow both Sean and I will be doing
Instagram live streams throughout the
day answering your questions about this
talking about this some more and
basically just telling you guys what we
have in store in the future we have
mostly upper body wear right now but we
will have leggings sweat pants shorts
we're gonna be expanding it throughout
this next year and next year next year
next year as we make this thing grow
bigger and better than we could ever
hope for so please go to cloak brand
comm check it out
actually be gentle with the website it
is something that we were just starting
you guys have a habit of breaking
everything that we tell you to go to but
please be careful I now realize that
both Sean and I are telling you to go to
the same website at the same time just
please be gentle with the website the
link is in the description if it's down
please don't spam it we're trying our
best here just be gentle with our baby
we just got it it's it's it's fresh it's
fragile please be careful with it
and remember you can submit a pre-order
right now at cloak brand comm and you
will get it before the end of the year
hopefully but does take time to make
clothing of this quality and we want to
make sure that everything is done right
so it's a good experience for everybody
buying from start to finish
so it's a pre-sale be careful with the
website baby please be careful gentle
with the baby so thank you everybody so
much for watching
I am super duper excited about this
I've been waiting so long I've been
bursting at the seams and I just can't
wait for you to see this stuff in person
it is the best clothing that I could
ever hope for this is something that I'm
gonna wear almost every single day so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye